this is lawrence it's teddy from seventh
grade why are you such a miserable [ __ ]
shut my life on the path to ruin and
this is funny to you you dried up
withered oh clam what are you smiling
about
my name is ted morgan and it's time to
punch out you're serious you came back
here to fight a bully and then kill
yourself jesus it's like jurassic park
when he walks teddy good to see you you
need to hurt me like i hurt you
bring the pain [ __ ] pants
just so you know it was twice the legal
limit say the same thing about your
boobies
that woman washes the ground i walk on
she spits in your coffee i've seen it
that is good tell them what your secret
ingredient is
love
ask you a favor could you help me kill
my dad why not this suicide thing
someone is gonna care ted morgan vicki
cerrone and they most likely won't ever
forgive you i want to give us a chance
we never had we have kids and uh husband
i never orgasm like that set me on fire
start with my eyes get out
my life is really complicated right now
kathleen
whoa
what are you doing
no no
i'm gonna wake her what vicky no one
said the path to killing yourself is
gonna be easy
you're both [ __ ]